newlywed bliss looks good on Jason
Aldean his first wedding anniversary
with brittany kerr is this March do
everything together you know she travels
on the road with me and you know she's
out here all the time jason tells ET
that family time is his absolute
favorite my daughter's come over having
them over there and all of us in the
same house and that that sort of my
favorite time and that brood which
currently includes two daughters from a
previous marriage may be expanding very
soon she's a lot younger than I am so
she's uh you know I got to make this
happen quick I don't want to be the old
dad so but yeah you know where it's
something we definitely want is you know
at least one kid and possibly two we'll
see but something where we've talked
about a lot and in a hole in the next
couple years Jason is set to hit stage
for New York's Farm Bureau country music
festival in june along with his tour
mate and fellow Georgia native Thomas
Rhett
Thomas married his longtime sweetheart
Lauren in 2012 she had been wanting me
to write just a sweet song for a long
time kind of something like just to see
you smile by tim mcgraw even though the
song sounds nothing like that the
sentiment that's sort of the same and so
I definitely wrote it you know with her
in mind and and you know all the lyrics
are kind of about us and our marriage my
relationship